ما الذي تسمعه من أصدقائك
والآخرين أه في روسيا عن
جهود الاحتجاج على الحرب للاحتجاج
بوتين
أم أشعر أنهم
أناس أعرف أنهم غاضبون للغاية
ولكن أيضًا في نفس الوقت
، الكثير منهم مرعوبون.
على سبيل
المثال قبل أسبوع قامت الشرطة
بضرب صديقة
لابنتي تبلغ من العمر 14 عامًا ، وصديقتها تبلغ من العمر 14 عامًا
أيضًا وذهبت مع والدها لحضور
احتجاج ضد الحرب
وبدأت الشرطة في ضربها وجاء والدها
إلى الشرطي وطلب
سألتها ماذا تفعلين هي في الرابعة عشرة من عمرها. لا
تفعل ذلك ، فبدلاً من ضرب الطفل ،
تحول الشرطي إلى ضرب
الأب ثم انتهى الأمر بأم الأب في
مركز الشرطة لبضعة أيام ، أو
تعرضت للضرب بوحشية
وأم  من هذا القبيل ، فهي
تحدث للأسف في كثير من الأحيان
، ولهذا السبب أعرف أن الكثير من
الروس يحاولون
مغادرة البلاد
ولكن هناك أيضًا عدد
من الأشخاص مقتنعين بأنه
لا ينبغي عليهم المغادرة لأنهم لا
يريدون العطاء
هذه روسيا باعتبارها أ  هدية لبوتين
ويريدون الوقوف على موقفهم
كيف تعتقد أن بوتين سيرد
على هذه العقوبات القاسية
من الغرب وأيضًا هذه
النكسات العسكرية في أوكرانيا هل
سينتقد أكثر حتى
أنني لا أعرف أنني  لست محللاً سياسيًا ،
لذلك لا أعرف حقًا ، لكنني
أعلم أن هذا هو الشيء الوحيد
الذي
يمكننا القيام به بشكل فعال ، ولهذا السبب أعتقد أن
سانشيز ضد العقوبات ضد
الكرملين ودعم الصمت
وأوكرانيا أمر بالغ الأهمية الآن ،
هل تعتقد أن بوتين  تدهورت صحته
العقلية وهذا هو السبب في أنه يتصرف
بهذه الطريقة أو أن هذا هو نفسه
فلاديمير بوتين العجوز الذي كنت تعرفه دائمًا ،
إنه فقط لم
يعاقب أبدًا على أفعاله السيئة خلال
العقدين الماضيين ،
وأعتقد أن هذه نتيجة عدم قيامه بذلك.
لم يحصل على رد أنه يستحق
أمه عندما غزا بوتين
شبه جزيرة القرم في عام 2014 ، وأه
بدأ الحرب في شرق أوكرانيا ،
لقد سمعنا الكثير من
التصريحات الكبيرة الصاخبة من
المجتمع العالمي ولكن المؤسف
لم يتم اتباع ذلك
ولم أشعر حقًا بأنه هو
وأقرب أعضاء حكم القلة وأصدقائه أه
عانى من الغزو في أوكرانيا
وأعتقد أن ما نراه الآن
في أوكرانيا هو نتيجة
الرضا عن العالم.  المجتمع
حول الوضع الذي حدث في
أوكرانيا 2014
لك